parler du président de la république qui
était hier à angoulême
à l'occasion du festival de la bd et le
président a été pris en photo vous
l'avez peut-être déjà vu avec un
dessinateur qui s'appelle jules et
surtout avec un tee shirt est sûre ce
tee-shirt il y à un personnage éborgné
et ce message
lb dès 2020 c'est évidemment une
allusion à l' usage des lanceurs de
balles de défense pendant les diverses
manifestations où les forces de l'ordre
l'ont utilisé que s'est il passé le
président de la république
était-il dans son rôle en posant avec ce
vêtement je vous propose d'écouter
d'abord le dessinateur jul celui qu'on
voit sur la photo et qui n'en revient
toujours pas il a dit il y a deux heures
à nos confrères de lci
en fait il y avait ce t-shirt qui était
censée marquer le 1 voilà un peu le
pointeur que cette discussion et avec
lequel lui il n'était pas d'accord
mais au moment de quitter la table on le
dit voilà on a aussi on en a fait un
port où il dira merci très bien et c'est
y aller et il a regardé il avait contre
lui des wc pamatai apprécié mais si vous
voulez on peut prendre une photo alors
j'ai dit sur le ton de la boutade
c'était absolument pas préparés ici de
notre part de l'assiette des enfants et
personne pour fait qu'il allait dire oui
alors on demande sa vie oui d'accord si
vous voulez voyez pas vraiment mes
oreilles si vous êtes sûr sur les blés
pont près d'une photo où oui pas de
problème voilà pas de problème est
effectivement le président de la
république l'a confirmé toujours à
angoulême est toujours hier en
expliquant qu' il avait accepté cette
photo au nom de la liberté d'expression
ce t-shirt dit quelque chose de très
profond c'est que dans notre pays la
liberté d'expression est réservé est
protégé mais même un pays il y en a peu
dans le monde où la liberté de blasphème
et protéger la liberté de critiquer tous
les dirigeants de les rails et de l'est
et ça c'est un trésor
voilà vous êtes très sévère sur sur les
réseaux sociaux dans vos commentaires
c'est une provocation à une menace
envers le peuple exprime dogues sur
youtube
le président ne peut et ne doit pas être
un militant nous dit fohrer et puis
branislav c'est pathétique et
inconvenant pour un président ce sont
ces citoyens qui ont perdu des yeux
blessés pour toute la vie alors donc ça
ça veut dire que ce branislav ce mais
plutôt du côté des gens qui ont été
blessés par les ailes bd y en a d'autres
qui sont pas non plus contents du tout
ce sont les policiers ce qui était de
l'autre côté de ce moyen de défense ou
d'attaqué comme on voudra écoutez la
réaction de stanislas godon c'est le
porte parole du syndicat alliance police
nationale
on peut faire des explications dans tous
les sens du scénario de comment ça s'est
déroulé pour arriver à cette photo ils
n'ont pas intéressant vers cern a forcé
la main au président de la république
sur cette photo lorsqu'il fait la photo
il fait la photo avec une image donc ils
acceptent le motif de l'image il ya
quinze jours il expliquait qu'il fallait
d'exemplarité dans nos rangs qui
demandaient des propositions du ministre
de l'intérieur et que c'était arrow
attention les policiers vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir
bon ça fait un peu beaucoup et je
l'avais dit après avoir maltraité sa
police l'état lâche sa police adriana
tout en appeler cette partie de la
mission mais à quoi joue mac ou parce
que c'est assez incompréhensible en fait
parce que quelques étés son intention je
comprends pas vraiment cette photo parce
que soit il veut défendre la police soit
il veut mettre l'accent sur les
violences peu de la police mais dans les
deux cas cette espèce de photos en
souriant avec un tee shirt
de caricature on parle quand même d'un
sujet un petit peu graves 40 personnes
éborgné des centaines voire des milliers
blessés des policiers très tendu de
l'autre côté je j'ai du mal à comprendre
serait surtout qu'apparemment il a
vraiment pas été forcée on a pu penser
que n'avait pas vu le t-shirt avec la
personne l'avait mise comme ça et en
fait non il et puis ce qui expliquerait
donc c'est un peu étonnant après il a
fait une autre intervention dans
laquelle ils récusent complètement le
terme de violences policières donc je
pense que c'est pour ça que
l'intervention du syndicaliste
d'alliance est peut-être un peu à côté
de la plaque parce qu'il est toujours
pour l'instant en vraiment en défense de
la police et même jusqu'à aligner le le
terme même de violences policières donc
voila mais cette photo est un peu
lunaire j'ai pas vraiment compris
l'intention du président et vous richard
oui vous avez compris l'intention non
pas trop et j'avoue que les propos de
jute sont un peu inquiétants ou voir un
peu hallucinant quand il décrit les
conditions dans lesquelles cette photo
c'est fait
en gros c'est très léger de la part du
président il est pas une espèce d'un
manque de distance terrible par rapport
au fait que voilà il va s'afficher sur
une photo dont on sait qu'elle va faire
le tour des réseaux sociaux et cie
affiche avec un sourire sur une photo
dans laquelle il ya ce t-shirt avec un
symbole qui est hyper fort et qui marque
en plus un débat de société dans le
moment qui est assez grave dans
l'insulté qui est très tendue ou à la
fois du côté des policiers comme du côté
des manifestants qui ont été abîmées par
enfin je trouve que voilà alors moi au
départ j'avais cru que c'était un peu le
côté descriptif de la communication du
président mais en fait c'est pas du tout
ça là il ya un manque de distance
complet ya une légèreté on lui passera
un tee shirt il le veut et après ils
rétropédale en disant c'est la liberté
d'expression 1
mais en fait voilà toute cette séquence
là elle m'a alors c'est très bizarre
parce que souvent on a dit ici sur ce
plateau qui avait une espèce de maîtrise
de la communication du président qu'il
aimait bien à les franchir des
frontières franchir des lignes jaunes
que ça faisait partie un peu du
personnage à qui vient qui l'aimé bien
cette provocation qui a ça faisait
partie aussi de cette volonté de faire
bouger la société mais là j'allais dire
il est presque pris à son propre piège
on le voit si jules nous raconte
exactement dans les conditions dans
lesquelles ça s'est passé je trouve
qu'il ya de la légèreté un manque de
distance terrible pour un président sur
un objet comme ça tu vas faire le tour
des réseaux sociaux dans la séquence
politique que l'on traverse où justement
les violences policières qu'il récuse
pas mais sont interrogés donc je trouve
que c'est très bizarre et pour le coup
moi j'y vois vraiment le côté la
déliquescence de la pole à la com du
président du moulin une explication sur
l'attitude du président mais j'allais
faire l'exégèse du maquereau nisme là
dessus je pense qu'il a quitté les
habits présidentiels que ce ce genre de
légèreté quelle que soit l'explication
qui puisse lui-même y apporter n'est pas
digne d'un président c'est quand même le
premier magistrat en sens d'une
magistrature seville et il est à la tête
de tous les fonctionnaires civils et
militaires et comme tel il se doit
d'avoir à certains hiératisme et une
certaine réserve qu'ils imposent aux
autres et donc à juste titre et donc il
se doit de se la poser lui-même
on parle d'un sujet grave on parle de
gens qui ont été à bord nié et encore
une fois le problème n'est pas ce
t-shirt le problème est que le président
lui-même pose avec et par certains côtés
on se souvient en souriant la grèce les
sourires et par certains côtés il y
rappelle il peut rappeler françois
hollande qui voit là c'est sa tactique
que emmanuel mâcon critiqué et qu'il y
avait une certaine de légèreté qui
sortait de la fonction de temps en temps
comme ça croyant être simple
être être naturel et être proche du
peuple mais alors là c'est un exercice
totalement manquée moi je comprends pas
qu'ils aient pas eu un conseiller de
l'elysée qui voyant la chose soit pas
arrivé et est exfiltré le président pour
empêcher un scénario comme c'était le 10
au minium sur le figaro live avec
gravité n'est ce pas pour éviter ce
genre de communication qui existent que
les conseillers en communication
et puis il ya nicole 0,6 ce qui
rapproche cette photo cl ibl sais pas si
ça vous paraît opportun de la photo
prise à saint martin avec les deux
jeunes blacks nous dit nicole 06
effectivement dont 1 faisait un doigt
d'honneur il a eu tort encore une fois
elle s'était fait piéger de la musique
bon moi je suis d'accord avec que
personne de quoi par le temps de prendre
une photo alors on lui remet un
tee-shirt arborant la photo oui c'est
une erreur de blessure je pense mais il
ya un moment le primat de la
communication
là une image qui va prendre le pas sur
toute parole surtout raisonnement
surtout dans trois jours on en parlera
plus le style and tall ils sont montés
au créneau des jeux succion dans trois
jours on en parlera plus et vous croyez
pas que l'image restera généralement une
persistance fait mais non puisque sur le
fond mais même écoutez moi même si ça
reste alors écoutez là on est en train
de dire qu'il faut raisonner en fonction
de ce que vont faire les réseaux sociaux
de toute image ce primat de la
communication richard zennoui à laurent
et il aurait dû penser mais non mais non
il faut pas il faut pas penser à ce
qu'on va faire bfm ou les réseaux
sociaux
sinon fait plus rien je je je ne trouve
pas ça gravissime et je préfère les
paroles et les raisonnements à une
l'image non mais ce qui est étonnant là
c'est que même si effectivement chez
look avec vous sur le fait que c'est pas
gravissime c'est que il ya l'image et
ensuite il ya la parole justement qui
justifie cela au nom de la liberté
d'expression c'est ça qui est un peu
bizarre
vahidi visé au festival de la bd
d'angoulême ont fait ce qu'il fallait
qu'ils prennent le tee shirt de jeu je
peux pas vous parler on aurait tenté
mais on aurait dû trancher pour la photo
et ça me ferait pas autant le sujet les
violences policières comparé discuter le
les défenses des enfin bon on peut dire
que tout ça mais là ça ne me paraît pas
traiter le sujet si on parle du traité
du on peut parler du sujet des violences
policières
on peut parler c on veut parler de tout
ça parlons-en ça c'est intéressant mais
une photo n'est pas intéressante
honnêtement et puis je laisse le dernier
mois christian qui sur figaro live nous
dit un président est donc la seule
personne qui ne peut pas s'exprimer
librement de toute évidence il le
regrette
parlons si vous le voulez bien d'un non
pardon nager pas donner l'avis des
internautes c'est important macron at il
fait une faute en posant avec ce tee
shirt et le bd basse et oui à plus des
deux tiers c'est une majorité strict
mais c'est pas non plus écrasant pour
tout vous dire je pensais que les
internautes seraient plus sévères
c'est formidable c'est pour ça qu'on
fait cette émission parce que les points
de vue des uns et des autres nous amène
à réfléchir et parfois être surpris